cannes sont strass et paillettes et ses
mini star yvelinoise sur la croisette
clémentine eva anouk aïssata carla
kimberley yousra et zhang-ke toutes les
huit sont scolarisés dans des collèges
et écoles de gargenville de vernouillet
et des mureaux elles ont eu la chance
cette année de venir à cannes à
l'occasion de la 15e édition du festival
défi en fait au début c'était un
concours avec pleins pleins d'école
c'était dans les yvelines dont il y
avait plein de villes qui y participer
et
bah on devait faire un concours de
critique on devait voir un film et faire
un concours de critique et du coup moi
j'ai été prise enfin ma critique a été
retenu c'est la cerise sur le gâteau
elle attendait ça cette année jeudi elle
puisque nous avons un jury de filles
cette année elles sont toujours très
heureuse quand on arrive
oui c'est magique tout l'ambiance elles
ont adoré l'autre jour quand nous sommes
allés à la montée des marches
elles ont vu george clooney julia
roberts eva longoria voilà en plus on a
eu de la chance puisque c'étaient des
gens qu'elle connaissait
elles ne connaissent pas toujours
parfois de grands réalisateurs que nous
on connaît mais les découvre il ya
toujours une grande curiosité un grand
appétit de savoir des choses qui est
cette personne
comment ça se passe où on va qu'est ce
qu'on fait c'est un peu comme une
communauté
oui un ensemble de personnes qui se
réunissent pour regarder des films à
discuter on allait au marineland sur la
croisette on a vu des stars
ensuite ce après midi tête qu'on va
aller sur des hits sur un bateau
histoire à est ce tout du rêve à la
réalité c'est l'histoire d'un jeune
plaisir wa enfants déjà quentin du qu il
était un passionné de cinéma et depuis
son bts audiovisuel
il multiplie ses projets cela fait
plusieurs années maintenant qu'il vient
à cannes pour présenter ses courts
métrages au short film corner un espace
dédié aux courts métrages
cinquième fois que j'ai à cames première
fois j'étais venu quand je faisais mes
études n'étaient plus en mode pas
touristes mais on découvre un petit peu
le festival est là sa quatrième fois que
je viens plus un mode professionnel pour
les projets pour travailler et c'est
cette année on a encore un nouveau film
sorti en corner et qui s'appelle
rencontre c'est une histoire toute
simple d'un homme et d'une femme
tous les jours il est lassé dans un
parent qui est voit une joggeuse qui
passe ils décident à l'aborder qui je
voue lamentablement à chaque fois mais
du coup cette fois ci il a un allié
assez puissant il a le temps avec lui ce
qu'il arrive à remonter dans le temps à
chaque fois pour pouvoir essayer encore
et encore de faire parler à cette file
on se connaît et meftah par 06 et tu
tombes ce soir j'ai un peu plus des mecs
comme toi
vous croyez tout faire mieux vous n'êtes
pas fan aux fans cette année un peu ça
j'ai plusieurs projets avec les canons
on revient donc sur les projets de longs
métrages concourent pas mal avancé on
continue à essayer de trouver des fonds
des producteurs pour monter ce projet là
j'ai aussi un projet qui s'appelle le
cross qui ans que je réalise avec un
resterait américains qui veulent à la
fois ci et c'est une série de c'est un
court métrage en six parties en fait
chacun de tourments réalise une partie
de cet épisode et du coup l'histoire se
crée au fur et à mesure se pressent
comme une impression musicale en vidéo
c'est à dire quand moi j'ai fait deux
premiers épisodes
voilà ne savais pas ce que j'allais
faire et il a fait son deuxième usine en
réponse aux premiers mois j'ai fait le
troisième en réponse institutes ainsi de
suite et donc on continue on est
vraiment c'est un projet qui est en
cours et ça va continuer à sortir
jusqu'au 11 septembre dans ma main je
dis pas de bêtises
enfin c'est notre star du jour c'est
melvil poupaud l'acteur originaire des
yvelines et à la fiche du film de justin
triais victoria aux côtés de virginie
efira et de vincent lacoste
un film présenté dans le cadre de la
semaine de la critique
c'est l'une des sections parallèles du
festival de cannes et victoria
l'histoire d'une avocate mère de famille
monoparentale amour sexe travail et
éducation tout s'entremêlent et
s'entrechoquent
alors le film c'est un portrait d'une
femme d'aujourd'hui c'est très
contemporain c'est virginie efira qui
essaye de gérer à la fois sa vie
professionnelle sa vie amoureuse et sa
vie de famille et qui est ils sont tous
là ils se moquent de moi déjà moi c'est
pareil je vais très très mal merde mais
on est tu vas tout le temps moi donc il
essaie de gérer sa vie c'est une très
belle femme très sexy et voilà et moi je
fais un type un peu allumé qu'elle doit
défendre lors d'un procès dans lequel on
m'accuse d'avoir agressé ma fiancée dit
toi une chose c'est que ta force c'est
ta beauté
c'est une blague non mais pour deux
raisons la première c'est que on peut
pas réellement croire qu'un beau même
voiture la deuxième c'est que
statistiquement les beaux gagnent plus
que le nez c'est pareil pour
l'intelligence tu vois les jurés y
seront toujours plus indulgent avec un
type intelligent qu'avec un débile parce
qu'ils s'identifient 178 c'est tout pour
aujourd'hui
et n'oubliez pas comme le dit jean luc
godard quand on va au cinéma on lève la
tête quand on regarde la télévision la
baisse